bonsoir nous sommes le vendredi 24 juin
nouvelle édition de votre journal de fin
de semaine voici les principaux titres
que nous allons aborder l'ancien premier
ministre de nicolas sarkozy en campagne
dans le département françois fillon
entend remonter dans les sondages il
fait intervenir ses principaux soutiens
des yvelines à commencer par gérard
larcher le président du sénat qui était
présent l'open de france se déroule du
30 juin au 3 juillet au golf national à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'heure des derniers préparatifs avant
de recevoir un plateau exceptionnel à
l'occasion de la 100e édition et comme
chaque vendredi
le zapping de l'information locale que
faut-il retenir de cette semaine entre
la probable hausse du passe navigo
en ile-de-france la fin des épreuves du
baccalauréat ou encore à l'ouverture des
soldes on débute ce journal par le brr
exit les anglais ont dit non à l'europe
un non franc à près de 52 % les
réactions se multiplient au niveau
national international je vous propose
d'écouter pierre lequiller députés les
républicains des yvelines il est aussi
conseiller régional et président de
l'association ile de france europe
pierre lequiller et l'ancien président
de la commission des affaires
européennes à l'assemblée nationale il a
également participé à l'élaboration du
traité de lisbonne ecoutez-le je suis
révolté parce que françois hollande a
été complètement inactif pendant quatre
ans sur les questions européennes et ils
proposent tous d'un seul coup d'aller
rencontrer madame merkel pour parler de
l'approfondissement de la zone euro s'il
ya longtemps qu'il aurait dit il aurait
dû aussi faire en sorte que rend
contrôle beaucoup mieux les décisions de
l'europe et qu'on est on s'attache non
pas au détail mai à des propositions de
politiques importantes qui intéresse
notre développement la boîte de pandore
ouverte et que
en tout 1 d'une vague un repli sur soi
des pays européens et même un effet
domino de sortie d'autres pays de
l'union européenne j'espère que non mais
ça trouve que c'est vraiment une
déflagration c'est vraiment un
traumatisme qui va au delà de la sortie
de la grande-bretagne
nous risquons d'avoir une situation
financière et économique va donner dans
les jours qui viennent
et donc c'est effectivement historique
je vous propose toujours sur ce sujet
d'écouté à présent la réaction d'un
couple anglais installés dans les
yvelines vous les avez découverts hier
dans ce journal ils espéraient que leur
pays pourrait rester dans l'europe un
peu déçu mais oui on va voir ce que ça
signifie pour le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
je pense que c'est la bonne décision
mais c'est ce que le public britannique
a voulu et voilà c'est la démocratie
je suis vraiment déçu c'est pas le
résultat que moi j'ai souhaité bon
maintenant il ya une période
d'incertitude pour nous et pour les les
les autres gens qui habitent en grand
bretagne qui savent pas il faut sortir
ou pas il nous reviendrons sur les
incidences du bre exit les conséquences
économiques notamment sur les
entreprises de notre secteur du
département des yvelines avec d'autres
réactions politiques se sera à suivre au
cours de nos prochaines éditions
nous poursuivons pour l'instant avec un
tout autre sujet cette nouvelle campagne
de communication du département des
yvelines le lancement a eu lieu cette
semaine un film institutionnel pour le
moins décalé un acteur a été recruté
pour mise en scène inattendue le film
sera diffusé notamment dans les salles
de cinéma de la région mais aussi au
delà jusqu'à la défense notamment afin
de faire découvrir les yvelines surtout
de faire comprendre aux touristes et aux
investisseurs que les activités
ne manquent pas en dehors du
mondialement reconnue château de
versailles une campagne d'affichage est
aussi lancée simultanément vous pourrez
les découvrir notamment sur les quais de
la gare montparnasse regarder en
attendant l'extrait le teaser de cette
nouvelle campagne vidéo du département
les yvelines ses musées son patrimoine
et son histoire
ah oui ce n'est pas que ça les yvelines
regardez si tout ça les yvelines comment
s'est déroulé le tournage justement et
puis les explications sur cette nouvelle
campagne promotionnelle c'est au micro
de nos confrères d'ign une première vous
savez le département des yvelines
impacte l'ensemble des yvelinois au
quotidien dans ses compétences le matin
vous déposez vos enfants la crèche c'est
une compétence du département des
yvelines vous les emmenez ensuite au
collège c'est une compétence du
département des yvelines
il déjeune dans une cantine scolaire
c'est une compétence du département des
yvelines
l'après-midi sur des structures
sportives multifonctions par exemple un
synthétique c'est le département des
yvelines et caetera et c'est jusqu'au
soir où lorsque vous allez voir par
exemple un de vos proches en résidence
pour personnes âgées
c'est une compétence du conseil
départemental des yvelines alors nous
avons voulu dans un ton décalé que l'on
doit à jean louis barcelona qui est un
acteur que vous connaissez bien et bien
donner un peu d'oxygène à sion et
interpeller le public et le grand public
j'explore de fond en comble les yvelines
je fais de la montgolfière je fais plein
de trucs et on découvre les yvelines
d'une manière complètement différente en
fait je fais la montgolfière j'ai eu
très très peur sur montgolfière j'ai
fait de la boxe je me suis pris oignon 1
brignon sur l'oeil droit et là j on va
peut-être arrêter sinon on va pas
continuer le tournage
après plusieurs mois d'appels à idées de
sélection le verdict est tombé à
maurepas les habitants ont voté pour die
projet du budget participatif met en
place par la ville ce sont deux projets
de rénovation qui arrive en tête le
skate park du stade du bois l aire de
jeu du bois de nogent et ils vont tête
c2r vont être remises à neuf
une enveloppe de cent cinquante mille
euros était prévu le skate park va donc
recevoir 85 mille euros pour un
aménagement des extensions de nous
module de nouvelles rampes aussi sur un
site plus sécurisé sont prévus et puis
environ 50000 euros restants qui seront
consacrés à l'air de jeu installé une
nouvelle clôture renouveler les
activités cela fait partie du cahier des
charges plus de 700 habitants ont pris
part à ce budget participatif c'est une
première pour la commune et face au
succès de cette première édition la
ville va renouveler certainement
l'opération d'année en année on écoute
le maire grégory arrestier c'est un
choix budgétaires et nous l'avons fléché
au budget primitif 2016 donc une
enveloppe de cent cinquante mille euros
que nous allons reconduire tous les ans
pour permettre justement où on va et
vient de déposer des projets et ensuite
de les soumettre au vote donc ça a très
bien marché
ça fait partie de dispositif de
démocratie locale que j'ai souhaité
mettre en place depuis que je suis élu
star d'associer vraiment les mots repas
siens à la décision
c'est sain c'est positif
et puis ça permet aussi à des norvégiens
de penser des projets auxquels même les
élus n'auraient pas pensé
propos recueillis par camille lambert
l'ancien premier ministre françois
fillon était à aubergenville dans les
yvelines mercredi soir un meeting dans
le cadre de sa candidature à la primaire
de la droite et du centre l'actuel
député de paris et troisième quatrième
homme de cette campagne si l'on en croit
les sondages mais il ne manque pas de
soutiens et notamment dans le
département gérard larcher le président
du sénat ce sénateur de rambouillet
était d'ailleurs présent pour
l'accueillir
son engagement est clair écoutez là je
suis à t'écouter
parce que je pense que tu es une chance
en notre pays une chose pour redresser
notre pays parce que tu incarnes se
faire et se faire tu la préparer tu l'a
préparée par ton expérience
par ta réflexion par les échanges que
nous avons eus les uns et les autres tu
es aussi un homme qui sait écouter
entendre partager alors je vous le dis
pour moi françois fillon incarne
vraiment une espérance pour notre pays
et je vais me battre à ses côtés de
toutes mes forces
de tout mon engagement est pas
simplement du bout des lèvres ou en
suivant les évolutions des uns et des
autres je suis avec françois fillon
je suis aussi pour que demain nos
famille politique du centre et de la
droite républicaine que nous gaulliste
nous offrions lâchant à une nouvelle
chance à notre pays si aussi le choix
d'expérience un meilleur processus de
primaires celui qui sortira des
primaires
le 27 novembre je le soutiendrai autre
soutien de françois fillon la sénatrice
sophie primas secrétaire départemental
du parti les républicains elle a
organisé la venue du candidat à
aubergenville dont elle est d'ailleurs
la mer
c'est en effet plus que jamais mon
candidat passe
un homme qui représente des valeurs qui
sont très chers pour moi pour la france
il se met plutôt en retrait par rapport
à ses convictions ce que ce qui je
trouvais est assez rare chez les hommes
politiques
et puis il a des valeurs d'autorité des
valeurs de liberté qui sont les valeurs
que je partage pour l'avenir de notre
pays
on lui reproche souvent d'être pas assez
expansif pas assez chaleureux
quelquefois en réalité c'est quelqu'un
qui est extrêmement chaleureux mais qui
a beaucoup de réserves et en fait je
pense que ça peut trancher au contraire
c'est sa différenciation à lui d'avoir
ce comportement qui est toujours le
sénat ne pas rogner ce qu'il est en
réalité et d'avoir un comportement qui
souvent comportement qu'ils n'opposent
personnes qui n'attaque personne qui ne
condamne personne mais qui est plutôt un
comportement avec de vraies de vraies
idées et de vraies motivations à
défendre d'autres pays
quant à françois fillon il a notamment
au cours de son discours abordé la
question du terrorisme
françois fillon qui a tenu à affirmer
que la france était en guerre qu'il
fallait renforcer les actions contre
l'état islamique dans le cadre d'une
coalition avec la russie notamment ou
encore l'iran on doit faire ça parce
qu'il ya le feu
et quand il ya un incendie on se pose
pas la question de savoir si on aime ses
voisins on est un incendie puis apprend
dispute wiston churchill avait une
formule après munich
quand les européens avaient capitulé
devant le nazisme et devant hitler
il avait dit à la chambre des communes à
au premier ministre britannique
il lui avait dit si hitler avait envahi
l'enfer et bien moi j'aurais trouvé des
mots aimables pour le diable est bien le
diable ça peut-être s'appelle peut-être
poutine il s'appelle peut-être bachar
el-assad
il faut trouver des mots aimables pour
conduire avec ces forces là la guerre
qui nous permettra d'éliminer l'état
islamique
françois fillon a aussi parlé à
d'immigration il a souhaité la mise en
place d'un quota annuel et puis un autre
point abordé au cours d'un échange avec
le public c'est la question du mariage
pour tous et même de l'avortement
comment l'ancien premier ministre a
répondu à ces questions de société de la
part des militants voici ses réponses
donc
j'ai commis une erreur je la reconnais
devant vous j'ai commis une erreur
quand j'ai écrit que l'avortement était
un droit fondamental c'est parce que je
voulais dire ce que je voulais dire
c'est que c'est un droit sur lequel
personne ne reviendra pas la peine je
comprends moins philosophiquement et
compte tenu de ma foi personnelle je ne
peux pas approuver l'avortement
messieurs en même temps un responsable
politique et je sais qui a une immense
majorité de français qui n'accepterai
pas qu'on revienne sur cette décision
c'est ce que je voulais dire et je les
dis d'une façon qui est tout à fait
maladroite
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que sur la question de la filiation et
du mariage pour tous
je suis le seul candidat enfin le seul
candidat qui je vais je vais vous
paraître prétentieux le seul candidat
qui a une petite chance de devenir
président de la république qui n'a
jamais changé de position sur la
question du mariage pour tous
j'ai dit depuis le début j'ai dit depuis
le début que j'étais contre j'ai voté
contre
j'ai fait un discours à l'assemblée que
vous pouvez allez retrouver j'ai dit
aussi que si malheureusement ce texte
passait personne ne supprimerait
abrogerait le symbole du mariage
homosexuel c'est à dire de la
reconnaissance de l'amour entre
personnes homosexuelles et que la seule
voie qui était réaliste c'était celle de
réécrire le droit de la filiation pour
séparer au fond le mariage homosexuel du
droit de la filiation
c'est à dire pour écrire dans le droit
qu'un enfant a toujours d'une manière ou
d'une autre un père et une mère
et pour conclure sur ce discours en
retiendra également quelques remarques à
l'encontre du gouvernement actuel un
président de la république qui vous
annoncent enfin dont le gouvernement
vous annonce à 10 heures qu'une
manifestation est interdite et à 13h
qu'elle est autorisée
c'est un président de la république
à aucune époque
son mandat a commencé avec leonardo qui
était une terrible démonstration de
faiblesse et d'humiliation pour la
fonction et pour la france
et ce mandat se termine enfin presque
malheureusement pas encore tout à fait
avec emmanuel macron pourquoi est-ce que
je reviens emmanuel macron parce qu
emmanuel macron c'est le conseiller
économique de france hollande celui qui
a conçu sa politique économique celle
qui se met en place en ce moment c'est
son ministre de l'économie et c'est un
monsieur qui actuellement marche dans la
france en disant aux français la
politique de françois hollande est nul
et il faut en changer et françois
hollande accepte ça sans sourciller que
pensent les électeurs potentiels de
françois fillon de cette intervention à
aubergenville au milieu de la semaine
sont ils convaincus de cette réunion
publique voici quelques réactions
j'ai trouvé que c'était très clair très
précis très nette
je trouve que c'est un homme posé et qui
a bien exprimé ce qu'ils voulaient faire
est vraiment je vais voter pour lui
c'est sûr et certain
une idée de la france que je partage
c'est quelqu'un qui revient je pense aux
bonnes méthodes à savoir dépasser les 35
heures venir
aux contrats d'apprentissage pour 14 ans
et j'avais déjà travaillé là dessus et
puis les passer un petit peu toutes ces
querelles et refaire monter la france
correctement voilà pour ce déplacement
de l'ancien premier ministre si vous
n'avez pas entendu le candidat françois
fillon répondre directement à nos
questions c'est tout simplement car il
était impossible d'obtenir un entretien
malgré nos demandes
plus d'une fois répétées auprès de ses
services autre sujet le 30 juin est
débutera la 100e édition de l'open de
golf c'est à saint quentin en yvelines
édition importante à moins de deux ans
de la ryder cup où en sont les
préparatifs michael et demi d'euros pour
ce reportage
j - 6 avant l'open de france de golf la
compétition qui fêtera cette année sa
100e édition sera organisée pendant
quatre jours sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
parcours totalement remodelée cette
année en vue de la ryder cup 2018 en
coulisses on peaufine les derniers
réglages
il ya encore deux semaines de travail
après tout les travaux qu'on a fait il
faut pas oublier qu avec l albatros été
fermée pendant neuf mois sur la période
et elle va on a fait 125 km de tranchées
pour bien drainé les parcours forcément
de ses 125 km départ qu il y ait encore
de système et encore le travail à faire
et ils nous versent une mauvaise mais
mais on est on est on est très près une
quarantaine de jardiniers des centaines
de personnes sont mobilisées dans la
logistique pour préparer cet événement
un travail rendu difficile avec les
conditions climatiques de ces dernières
semaines on a roulé moins des duels les
plus en plus bio de la dernière 105
convenance c'est vrai que même avec tous
les travaux qu'on a fait les parcours il
peut plus se voiler la quête tourne et
on n'est qu'au l'accès à l'eau
la morale des cabinets on est vraiment
on a mis le soleil selon les
météorologues du golf national le soleil
devrait être de la partie pour l'open de
quoi ravir les 55000 à 60000 spectateurs
qui seront présents sur les quatre jours
de compétition depuis le début du mois
la fromagerie de ludovic bisous est
officiellement une ambassade de la
gourmandise il a été élu meilleur
ouvrier de france en 2015 ce fromage et
de rambouillet accumule les distinctions
le son nouveau titre a été a décerné par
l'académie nationale de gourmandise
manon labat le fromage un produit qui a
du sens depuis la nuit des temps pour
ludovic biseau la boutique de ce
meilleur ouvrier de france situé à
rambouillet est l'un des premiers de
l'hexagone à avoir sur sa devanture une
plaque d'ambassade de la gourmandise
oui j'ai triplé mes prix immédiatement
et j'ai installé un service de voiturier
pour les rolls qui viennent re est tout
à fait le fromager affineur allie
qualité et humour dans son commerce il
est notamment à l'initiative d'un
tournoi baptisé roland claque hausse
cette nouvelle distinction lui a été
décernée par l'académie nationale de
gourmandise qui compte dans ses rangs
david douillet ou encore le prince
guillaume de triche c'est pas une
opération
mercantile pas du tout c'est un titre un
peu honorifique qui voilà qui a un écho
médiatique qui rend les mes clients ici
à rambouillet très fier et moi aussi
donc voilà c'est chouette
ludovic biseau s'envole aujourd'hui à
new york pour la ligue des fromagers
extraordinaire pour permettre à notre
patrimoine gastronomique de traverser
les frontières
comme chaque vendredi dans ce journal
nous passons maintenant à l'essentiel de
la semaine que faut-il retenir voici ce
montage en cas de brick site
les conséquences peuvent être
importantes pour les britanniques vivant
en france notamment concernant la
situation administrative
est-ce qu'on va revenir à la cape de
séjour bon ça c'est pas très grave mais
c'est en va encore plus loin que ça
peut-être et à tes questions est-ce
qu'on peut rester ou pas voilà comme la
famille watson de nombreux britanniques
vivant en france espère le maintien du
royaume uni appliquer une taxe valls
c'est la mesure proposée par valérie
pécresse pour financer le pass navigo à
tarif unique mise en place par son
prédécesseur
selon la présidente de la région ile de
france le coût du forfait mensuel
s'élèverait à 450 millions d'euros
chaque année pour le stif 150 millions
d'euros seraient remboursés par
l'augmentation d'une taxe payée par les
employeurs
le reste n'aurait pour le moment pas de
plan de financement
une vingtaine de mesures pour défendre
l'esprit d'entreprise et favoriser la
croissance c'est la proposition de
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés l'association a rédigé un livre
blanc qu'elle a remis le 22 juin nicolas
sarkozy président du parti les
républicains un ouvrage élaboré à partir
de discussions entre entrepreneurs et
figures politiques il ya beaucoup de
gens qui s'expriment en france très bien
qu'ils parlent très bien mais qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils ne connaissent
pas les réalités de l'économie
mondialisée
là c'est vraiment
geslin fonderie c'est des gens qui
comprennent qu'ils viennent de la
mondialisation qui tiennent la france
qui aime l'entreprise française et c'est
la délivrance pour lycéens de terminale
le bac c'est enfin terminé au moins
jusqu'aux résultats avec peut-être les
rattrapages les dernières épreuves se
sont déroulées aujourd'hui avec les
mathématiques pour les filières es et
les ailes
les scientifiques eux ont passé les
épreuves de biologie mais le répit sera
de courte durée les futurs bacheliers
doivent attendre le 5 juillet pour
connaître le verdict plus moderne mais
aussi plus accessible la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines se
renouvelle elle a mis en place de
nouveaux dispositifs dont un outil
multilingue les usages et malentendants
ou ne parlant pas français ont accès aux
questions les plus souvent posées dans
leur langue
une première en france dès septembre
prochain
cette classe accueillera sept nouveaux
élèves des petits yvelinois âgé de trois
ans est atteint d'autisme ou de troubles
envahissants du développement
cette unité d'enseignement maternel
autisme appelé em est une première dans
le département
une enseignante spécialisée expérimenté
s'occupera de cette classe j'attends
cette ouverture depuis depuis très très
longtemps
effectivement l'autisme c'est un
handicap qui a été très peu reconnu ces
dernières années il ya des assurances
qui prendront certaines choses en charge
l'état va nous aider aussi on l'espère
mais on a besoin aussi d'avoir un
soutien rapide un petit peu de nos amis
que qu'on nous montre un petit peu de la
solidarité pour le lieu est un amour tu
de cette maison laissée par aragon et
elsa triolet et donc tout coup de pouce
vraiment est le bienvenu en ce moment
une derrière ses grilles de plusieurs
mètres d'eau situé chemin de bellevue et
à louveciennes se cache la maison la
plus chère du monde
bâti sur le modèle du château de
vaux-le-vicomte la demeure privée
construite en 2011 a été vendu 275
millions d'euros
l'acheteur bénéficie de 23 hectares de
terrain est un château moderne de 5000
mètres carrés équipée d'une salle de
cinéma de mobilier du xviie siècle et de
plusieurs piscines les ventes privées et
le e-commerce défavorise parfois les
soldes mais auch et n'ai pas
d'inquiétude les 180 enseignes du centre
sont confiantes
les soldes restent un rendez vous
incontournable comme le premier semestre
a été un petit peu compliqué en raison
effectivement d'un climat social chargé
d'une météo qui a été c'est peu clémente
forcément il ya du stock il ya une envie
de vendre de faire la passe par une
belle collection et les clients aussi en
vue de s'équiper pouvoir partir en
vacances donc à il ya un enthousiasme et
une envie partagée
au retour des vestiaires les bleus
perdent la main sur le match
de l'impatience règne dans la salle
jusqu'à la rentrée de dimitri payet et
sa reprise de volée à la 77e minute sur
la transversale qui réveille le public
score final 0 à 0 les réactions après la
rencontre sont mitigés entre espoirs et
déceptions ou mécontents ou poursuivre
l'aventuré avec le formidable de jouer
contre la france
on est bien sûr convaincu qu'on en
entendra beaucoup parler de ce match
bon c'est un jeu là pour nous et puis le
fait que ben on va dire souci une petite
revanche à 9h 2010 donc de français
renoncent pour se sortir de la presse un
très beau match qui à mon sens veut est
très ouvert mise en place en france en
1983 la fête de la musique continue de
faire vibrer cette année encore 120 pays
ils ont célébré
et l'actualité de cette semaine c'est
aussi la loi travaille toujours contesté
dans la rue débattu au sénat un climat
particulier pour son président est
gérard larcher et le gouverner c'est ce
qu'attendent les français
ils attendent un gouvernement qui fixe
un cap et nous voyons bien que c'est ce
qu'attendent les français pour les temps
qui viennent
c'est le débat que nous allons avoir
pour l'élection présidentielle
quels projets mais aussi quelle manière
d'être gouvernés en fait ce qu à qena se
termine dans une forme de palinodies que
ce dossier sur la manifestation illustre
moi j'ai rencontré tous les partenaires
sociaux ils doivent respecter les règles
de la république ce fils ne les respecte
pas ses taux à l'exécutif de décider si
une manifestation peut se tenir ou non
pour des intérêts d'ordre public et en
même temps ce gouvernement a raté
complètement le temps du dialogue social
pour terminer ce sujet quelques-uns pour
terminer ce journal quelques-uns des
sujets que nous développerons à partir
de lundi et la course au logement pour
les étudiants afin de les aider dans
leur recherche un forum est proposé dès
demain samedi à saint quentin en
yvelines dans la toute nouvelle maison
de l'étudiant du campus de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est sur la commune de
guyancourt à partir de à 10 heures
l'euro 2016 se poursuit les bleus en
huitièmes de finale ce week end on
l'espère une compétition qui va se
poursuivre pour eux nous ferons
régulièrement un point le point sur
l'ambiance dans les yvelines et
notamment du côté de versailles ou
l'irlande est installé nous verrons si
l'engouement du public va se poursuivre
autour des équipes nationales
un dernier mot concernant la
programmation de nos confrères de radio
sensations nicolas kirillovitch reçoit
dimanche à 18 heures jean frédéric
poisson député de rambouillet candidats
à la primaire à droite
voici un extrait de cette interview
concernant la prochaine présidentielle
et la primaire de la droite et du centre
vous dites qu aujourd'hui on en fait on
est dans une élection à 4 à 4 tours
c'est une élection à 4 tours et des
faits risque d'user le candidat et puis
aussi la saison du helmand les gens
certainement c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
commence à voir avec eux la candidature
d'alain juppé qui commence à décrocher
parce que il est en campagne depuis très
longtemps
de mon point de vue beaucoup trop
longtemps et c'est pas moi qui fait sa
stratégie saas est la sienne et je pense
qu'en tout cas la primaire elle
installera un candidat qui sortira des
urnes de ses deux tours de scrutin bien
sûr le 20 septembre prochain
je ne pense pas qu'elle réglera à elle
seule le problème du leadership ou de la
désignation du chef qui est le problème
car nous avons un vase avait répondu à
ma prochaine question est-ce que je suis
donc c'est les candidats qui seront qui
vont se présenter capable de se réunir
le soir du 27 novembre derrière un
candidat si vous vous y engager selon
c'est indispensable si vous y croyez
c'est pas d'y croire c'est de le faire
et loisirs avec le 7-8 week end préparée
et présentée par mélanie poquet rendez
vous lundi à partir de 18h en direct
pour le journal avec florane parfait 19h
pour la première rediffusion d'ici là
vous pouvez aussi nous suivre et
commenter nos programmes sur les réseaux
sociaux très bon week end